und diese schuhe sind gerade mega in
halb das problem ist nur die sind
eigentlich in vielen läden in
deutschland ausverkauft etwas gedauert
und es willkommen bei einem neuen video
ja leute ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
heute mal wieder mit einem etwas anderen
video es geht heute nämlich um session
in anführungszeichen also ich bin jetzt
natürlich kein fashion youtuber ich
kenne mich auch mit feschen nicht so gut
aus wie andere ja das sage ich immer
ganz gerne vorbei aber es geht heute um
eine menge coole klamotten ich hab
nämlich wieder einen kooperation mit
jockey hat punkt kommen einige coole
klamotten zugeschickt bekommen egal ob
zur t shirts jacken oder caps ist
eigentlich alles dabei
ich würde sagen ich zeige euch das gern
mal wieder wie ich das kombinieren würde
vielleicht auch zum teil für den sommer
und es sind natürlich alles sachen die
eigentlich unisex sind die können auch
mädchen tragen also ist jetzt nicht nur
für jungs vor allem eigentlich auch die
schuhe und alle sachen sind wie immer
und in der video beschreibung verlinkt
deswegen wenn ihr sagt hey bist teil
hätte ich gern mal an im shop einfach
und in der video beschreibung schauen
vor allem die schuhe feiere ich mega und
ich würde sagen wir fangen an mit dem
ersten teil und das ist dieses hier
scheiß jetzt habe ich keine - zu würfeln
kann muss ich wohl selber machen so
leute wir haben hier von adidas ein
langarm jersey footballer sie nennt man
das glaube ich so sieht das aus hier
langarm mit dem adidas streifen und dem
adidas logo drauf die qualität ist echt
richtig gut und ich feiere so eine
qualität richtig also in diesem sport
ziel das ist halt so ein bisschen aber
ich hatte mir letztens auch so ein
grünes davon geholt und wie das wir
tragen aussieht zeige ich euch jetzt
[Musik]
heute ganz wichtig habe ich eben
vergessen zu sagen mit dem kot alex w 15
bekommt ihr 15 prozent rabatt auf die
gesamte bestellung also es lohnt sich
auf jeden fall dran kommen wir als
nächstes zu einer hose und zwar haben
wir hier eine hose original von junk
jahr die hose fällt ein bisschen weiter
aus kann man aber trotzdem ganz cool
anziehen
als ich die bestellt habe habe ich
gedacht dass sie ein bisschen anders ist
also ähnlich wie der jobbörse ist leider
nicht der fall
trotzdem zeige ich euch natürlich wie
das aussehen könnte und vielleicht auch
was man dazu anziehen könnte hier habe
ich ein ja so eine jacke mit
reißverschluss also der nicht ganz
aufgeht also es ist eine mischung aus
einem pulli und jacke von reebok finde
ich auch cool die marke gefällt mir sehr
das outfit müsste auf jeden fall sehr
sportlich aussehen und ja ich würde
sagen schaut doch mal rein
[Musik]
als nächstes kommen wir zu einem teil
dass ich übelst feier also das war so
eine sache wenn mir jetzt irgendwer
klamotten zeigen würde und die links in
die beschreibung packen würde und mir
diesen pulli zeigt da würde ich wirklich
sehr sehr gerne zugreifen und zwar haben
wir hier einen orangenen vieler pulli
mit weißen und blauen akzenten kann man
nicht sagen aber
also da kann wirklich jeder sagen was er
will der pulli ist einfach geil ich
glaube das könnte so mein lieblingspulli
werden und wenn man den anzieht mit nach
raschen hose dabei könnte das ungefähr
so aussehen
[Musik]
also der pulli auch auf jeden fall und
in der video schwemme verlinkt schauten
vorbei was sich aber auch noch ganz
wichtig dazu sagen wollte diese sachen
sind natürlich alles markenklamotten es
muss jetzt nicht heißen dass sie viel
besser sind als neue klamotten zum
beispiel dieses t shirt hier ist absolut
norm und sie trotzdem cool aus also ich
will jetzt hier nicht das bild
verschaffen ihr seid nur mega cool wenn
ihr euch so ein vieler politik auf für
80 euro hat er gekostet natürlich ist
das normal für solche pullover und ich
finde wenn er so gut aussieht ist ja
auch mal diesen preis wert aber da muss
natürlich jeder selber wissen und wir
machen weiter in folgendem teil und zwar
haben wir hier von kappa dieses war
eigentlich eine art jacke die man gut
mal abends anziehen kann wenn es
eigentlich war mist aber ja jetzt vor
allem zu dieser zeit ein bisschen kälter
wird abends von kappa hier muss ich auch
sagen die marke feiere ich brutal ich
weiß gar nicht hatte vor einem monat gar
nicht auf dem schirm
dass die wirklich auch so street
klamotten machen die man mal eben in der
freizeit anziehen kann wollen wir vorne
drauf und noch mit einem katalog schön
aufgestickt in ja so gold silber ist das
könnte man meiner meinung nach auf jeden
fall auch sehr sportlich kombinieren
vielleicht so als alternative zu dem
oberteil habe ich mir noch dieses hier
bestellt das könnte man eigentlich also
hier haben wir jetzt ein ganz normales
trainingsjacke von kappa die setzt echt
richtig gut wie angegossen
[Musik]
also ich feiere das mega vor allem
dieser sportliche look habe ich genau
die passende größe gewählt ich bin
ungefähr 1 80 groß das ist jetzt hier
trainiere ja das müsste es sein wie
schutz bestelle ich immer ein elvis und
jacken mittlerweile eigentlich über 1 m
natürlich fällt es ja auch immer
unterschiedlich groß aus aber ich hatte
jetzt in der vergangenheit zwei policen
elfer
die waren wirklich zu ross heißt es ging
gar nicht klar so wir haben doch diese
sunny das shirt ist ein t shirt wirklich
perfekt für den sommer sehr schlicht
einfach mit adidas logo drauf kostet
glaube ich 24 euro war ein bisschen
runter gesetzt kann man auf jeden fall
auch gutmann schnapper machen auf der
seite irgendwas was halt runtergesetzt
vielleicht weil es nicht mehr in so
einer großen auswahl vorhanden ist und
so weiter also schaut auf jeden fall
gerne vorbei dazu vielleicht diese ali
das capped habe ich mir auch noch
gegönnt
für nur 1 euro die kriegt man sonst
eigentlich nirgendwo für neun euro
kosten normalerweise 25 euro und ja die
kann man so tragen gefällt mir
eigentlich auch so viel besser als wenn
ich sie jetzt worum aufsetzen würde weil
die relativ hoch ist und ich wirklich
ganz dringend mal wieder zum friseur
gehen sollte so ich will mal sagen wir
kommen zu den schul und zwar kommen wir
zum ersten schuh ist vom fehler ich
finde die mag ist gerade extremen kommen
die sache nicht brutal und diese schuhe
sind gerade mega im halb das problem ist
nur die sind eigentlich in vielen läden
in deutschland ausverkauft und zwar
meine ich genau diese hier tragen sehr
sehr viele mädchen gibt es allerdings
auch für jungs ich habe mich einfach mal
geholt ich hatte die noch nicht an
wir werden gleich mal live sehen wie das
aussieht also wenn ihr auf der suche
nach diesem schon seid dann bestellt
euch sie auf jeden fall in diesem schock
[Musik]
weil hier gibt es da noch in allen
verschiedenen größen ich verlinke euch
das natürlich in der video beschreibung
weiße schuhe sind halt meiner meinung
nach einfach das geilste was man machen
kann
da kann man nie was man falsch machen
außer dass sie halt wahrscheinlich bei
mir höchstens zwei monate heilig werden
viel spaß aber meine weißen schuhe
werden echt immer sehr schnell dreckig
da muss ich vorsichtig damit umgehen
das muss ich mir jetzt fest vornehmen
und ich zeige euch noch ein gutes
anderes paar da hat alles für mich auch
ein schnapper gemacht und zwar haben wir
hier von adidas diese schuhe waren auch
unter gesetzt ich auch nochmal mit
anderen schnürsenkeln krank auch in der
wiederbestellung verlinkt und leute zum
schluss habe ich noch gar nicht
ausgepackt haben wir noch eine ja ich
sag einfach mal windjacke von viele
leute da hätte ich jetzt ich habe mir
nur so gesehen in der verpackung schaut
euch diese ärmel an
ich habe mich jetzt schon verliebt eine
wirklich geniale jacke für jungs und
mädchen natürlich auch in der video
beschreibung verlegen sich ziehen sie
mal kurz jetzt schon an
das ist einfach genau mein stil es fällt
natürlich auf aber die sieht echt heftig
aus danke an dieser stelle
[Musik]
leute das war's mit dem video wenn ihr
noch bock habt auf den nächsten part
nächsten monaten last auf jeden fall
einen fetten daumen nach oben da schon
gerne im shop vorbei allerdings wie
gesagt auf myvideo beschreibung wir
sehen uns morgen wieder morgen gibt's
neues video und ja ich wünsche euch
einen schönen tag eine schöne rest woche
schönes langes wochenende und heute